[Music]
anyone
hello everyone with the mediums release
date fast approaching
we wanted to share with you nine curious
details about the game
that you probably never heard about
so let's take a deep breath and start
counting
number one the core idea of the medium
and of the two simultaneous worlds
started back in 2012.
the game was initially to be released on
wii u xbox 360
and the playstation 3. although it was
pretty much a different game back then
you can still find mentions of the
medium online
with the initial announcement in the
form of an actual postcard
still floating on the internet our times
have changed when it comes to marketing
games
number two two key characters of the
game marianne
and the nameless man that's bent on
revenge have been based on two famous
polish actors
veronica rosati who you will soon see in
never gonna snow again
help design marianne i need your help
first
while the man uses the likeness of
martin tarachinsky
[Music]
you can recognize as vasily borghoff
from the netflix original series
the queen's gambit number three
the medium is somewhat of a reunion tour
of the silent hill
dream team the game soundtrack is
co-created with sonnet hill's main
composer
akira yamaoka mary elizabeth makes her
return with vocals
[Music]
or troy baker plays the character of the
mall
why hide
silly little girl number four
the medium takes you to an abandoned
hotel called liva
although the name has been changed for
the game the place it actually does
exist
the real name is hotel krakovia and is
located in the city centre of krakow
poland the developers they wanted to
give it a one-to-one rendition
so they went and explored the place to
carefully recreate its atmosphere
you can take a look at it on google maps
in case you want to visit the place
before the game is released
[Music]
number 5 marion's home where the game
starts
is located in a real apartment building
in krakow poland
near mataka square curiously
the same building or rather what it
would be like in 2084
can also be found in blooper team's
previous release observer
system redux
number six all the cutscenes were mocked
and recorded by the lead developers
and meant as precise references for the
motion capture actors
these mock-ups proved invaluable when
the pandemic hit
and the proper recording sessions had to
be directed remotely
for the mocap sessions of the mall
bluebird team hired an actor
walking on stilts to better depict the
creature's towering posture
all in all the game has around 90
minutes of cutscenes
within an 8 to 10 hour long game with
some of the cutscenes using the dual
reality mechanic
so you can watch the events unfold from
two different perspectives
number seven you can check the level of
your spirit energy by looking at
marion's arm
this is just one of the ways that
developers wanted to make the game's ui
as minimal as they can so that the
players can immerse into the medium's
world
as much as possible number eight
the game takes place in an abandoned
communist resort so naturally
there are quite a few mentions and
objects in the game connected to that
era
including a wrecked mallow a cult
classic tiny polish car
now valued by fans of retro automobiles
worldwide
and finally number nine the medium hides
a lot of secrets pop culture references
and little easter eggs you can find
allusions to bloomberg team's previous
games
or for example spot some of the
developers on
postage stamps let us know what you
found once you get to play the game
happy hunting
[Music]
you